but i can only announce today for the
european commission
that we want to pledge 1 billion euros
600 million of those will go to ukraine
to the ukrainian authorities and
partially to the united nations so that
the ukrainian authorities can who know
exactly who is in need can distribute
that and 400 million euros will go to
the frontline states that are doing such
an outstanding job and helping the
refugees that are coming above all we
are sending a message to every single
ukrainian in the cities and villages
under siege
a message of hope to the brave ukrainian
soldiers heroes defending their country
from the aggressor
dear brothers and sisters
you are not alone
much has been done
however in near future ukraine will
require huge economic boost similar to
the one offered to western europe after
world war ii a new martial plan for
ukraine my friends
as a humanitarian crisis deepens and
needs continue to grow our collective
response must keep pace that's exactly
why we're gathered here today
together let's keep working to mobilize
governments around the world private
companies and the people in our
communities to support refugees from
ukraine and indeed support all
ukrainians they have to do everything to
force russia to seek peace
they have to do everything to hold
russian soldiers and their commanders
accountable for their crimes against the
ukrainian people
sanctions
must be imposed
against all russian banks
russian oil embargo must be imposed we
have asked for weapons we've asked for
financial assistance we have asked for
support to ukrainian negras for those 10
million people forced by russian to flee
their homes
the democratic world had the power to
help
ukrainian courage deserves respect
the russian war crimes machine should be
denied its capacity to act
we have not only find
structural
decisions to what to deal with how to
deal with consequences but we also have
to see the roots of the system and now
the system is paid based on fossil fuels
and it's based now on buying them and
you are now fueling this war europe is
now
fueling this war world is doing it
35 billion euros since 24th february
yeah 1 billion for ukraine it is
definitely a competition for ukraine
elections
and we are here today to stand for
ukraine and arena we thank you we thank
you so much for the system the system of
fossil fuels
[Applause]